and they lived happily ever after or
maybe not from sci-fi Classics to Pixar
hits these sequels weren't afraid to
throw away the pleasant endings of their
previous installments level beloved 1997
film Men In Black opened with Agent K on
a mission with his longtime partner
agent D after d fumbles with his weapon
and he's K to save him D realizes he's
too old for Galaxy saving and decides to
retire things eventually come full
circle by the end of the film with K
revealing that he had been training a
replacement rather than a partner in
Agent J after J memory wipes his friend
the older agent finally gets to return
to his old life and the wife you left
behind over 30 years prior among the
images at the end of the movie is a
newspaper headline that shows a happy
couple reunited at last despite the
first movie establishing that Jay's new
partner was meant to be agent L things
didn't work out that way actor Linda
fiorentino didn't return for 2002's Men
In Black 2. so instead Tommy Lee Jones
was brought back to team up with Agent J
once again you're back no how'd you know
his head would grow back
Gross Back sadly in Universe this means
that K had to be pulled out of
retirement and forced to once again
leave behind the wife that he was
frequently shown pining after in the
first movie
in hindsight it might seem like a
no-brainer that the Victory celebration
at the end of the first Star Wars movie
was going to be short-lived that's at
the time when the movie was mostly known
as Star Wars rather than Star Wars
Episode 4 a new hope it wasn't
necessarily a foregone conclusion that a
sequel was in the Stars thus A New Hope
ends the way it does with a lavish
ceremony in which the heroes are awarded
medals for dispatching the bad guys as
proof of that so the mere fact that the
1980 sequel The Empire Strikes Back even
existed at all immediately showed that
Luke Skywalker and Han Solo's Awards may
have been premature to say the least
with each successive sequel showing
things in the Galaxy getting worse and
worse the lavish ceremony that ends a
New Hope has felt increasingly more
jarring and out of place
with Austin Powers being a parody of
James Bond and other movie Spies of the
60s and 70s it was to be expected that
he wasn't going to stay settled down
with Vanessa Kensington despite the 1997
movie ending with their marriage besides
trailers and advertisements for the 1999
sequel Austin Powers The Spy Who shagged
me featured a whole lot of Felicity
shagwell so Vanessa had to be pushed
aside to allow for Austin and Felicity
to hook up and pushed aside Vanessa was
in the very first scene of the movie
drawing the couple's romantic honeymoon
Austin makes a discovery that his wife
is a fem boss when she attacks him and
self-destructs she was apparently a fem
boss all along despite being the
daughter of Austin's partner from back
in the 1960s does that make any sense
not really but if you ask a basil
Exposition it doesn't really matter I
suggest you don't worry about this sort
of thing and just enjoy yourself
that goes for you all too
yes once horror movie sequels become
commonplace it was rare that they ended
on any kind of an overwhelmingly
positive note after all filmmakers
always had to leave that dangling threat
of a possible Return of the villain but
horror sequels weren't always a given
and as a result the first installments
of many future franchises ended in more
concrete ways that allow viewers to
imagine their Heroes living long and
happy lives take 1980s Friday the 13th
for instance which features Alice Hardy
getting the chance to survive Mrs
Voorhees Rampage at Camp Crystal Lake
however instead of getting to be an
ongoing presence in the series in the
same vein as Laurie strodean Halloween
or Sydney Prescott and scream Alice
takes an ice pick to the temple in the
opening scene of 1981's Friday the 13th
Part Two from final girls of first kill
is definitely a long way to fall the
mid-2010s were a dark time for comedy
movie sequels as cult favorites like
Anchorman and Joe Dirt were dusted off
for extremely disappointing follow-ups
part of that Trend was 2016's Zoolander
2. in which Ben Stiller returned as a
titular supermodel the original
Zoolander received only a lukewarm
critical reception and didn't exactly
set the box office on fire like
supermodels carelessly follow King and
gasoline but it obviously had enough
fans for Stiller to be able to direct
and star in a sequel 15 years later for
whatever reason still around his
co-writers decided to restart the story
by having the Derek Zoolander Center for
kids who can't read good and who want to
learn to do other stuff good too
collapse just two days after opening
killing his girlfriend Matilda in the
process if you thought Matilda was
killed off because of issues with actor
Christine Taylor you'd be wrong she
reprized her role as Matilda's ghost to
give Derek's new love interest her
blessing go to her Derek
you're cool with it
really cool with it
I'm dead perhaps Taylor was only
available for a single day of shooting
whenever people talk about how terrible
movie adaptations of video games
typically are is because movies like
Mortal Kombat Annihilation set the bar
so very very low it's especially
disappointing because the original 1995
Mortal Kombat movie was actually pretty
good and was the first inkling that
movies based on video games could be
halfway decent if handled properly while
Mortal Kombat already has its own Happy
Endings spoiled in that movie's final
moments but Shao Khan interrupting the
victory celebrations to set the stage
for his attack in the sequel 1997's
Annihilation still took things to
another level in a moment that has
shocked and angered Gamers across the
world Shao Khan murders Johnny Cage one
of the original movies main Heroes
literally minutes into the sequel of
course this puts an end to the budding
relationship between him and Sonia Blade
the Mortal Kombat film franchise itself
was also murdered by this movie and it
would take an astounding 24 years for it
to be resurrected with its reboot in
2021 perhaps it was asking too much to
let Dante Hicks catch a break as being
beaten down by life at every turn is
basically what defines him as a
character in the clerk's franchise still
fans saw that maybe he had at least
finally gotten his love life situated by
the end of 2006's Clerks too leaving
behind the fiance he clearly wasn't
right for in favor of his manager at
Movies Becky between getting engaged to
Becky and starting a business with his
best friend Randall Clerks 2 actually
seem to be setting up a pretty good life
for Dante despite the release of posters
and trailers for 2022's clerks 3
featuring Becky it's revealed in the
film's opening minutes that Becky was
killed by a drunk driver in the time
that had passed since the last movie to
make things even more tragic we also
learned that she was pregnant with the
couple's child at the time we only knew
each other for like 15 minutes you've
been mourning me for like 15 years so
what do you want me to do you want me to
just forget about you filmmaker Kevin
Smith has never been afraid to take his
comedies into dark territory but this
might have been the most upsetting twist
he has ever put into one of his films
that's saying a lot considering he also
made the horror movie Tusk the 1984
original Ghostbusters ends with the
titular team having saved New York City
and the entire world from the malevolent
goza once they have become common
knowledge that ghosts were real and that
Peter Venkman and his team at the means
to effectively bust them the
Ghostbusters should have been able to
keep plenty busy forever respected for
their past present and future heroics
instead 1989's Ghostbusters 2 starts
with the first hint of that spectral
slime that will surely require the
Busters to be called into action however
that Eerie opening is immediately
followed by another scene that sees Ryan
Winston performing at a child's birthday
party to make ends meet the kids even
Boo the two former Heroes of humanity
immediately establishing the
Ghostbusters as lame husbands despite
their incredible accomplishments five
years prior the two main protagonists of
2012's Wreck-It Ralph Ralph and
Vanellope both feel like they don't
belong in their respective arcade games
over the course of the movie though they
each learn how to make a living in their
own games on their own terms Ralph goes
to great lens to help Vanellope learn
that she isn't just a glitch finally
making her feel a sense of belonging
then there's a 2018 sequel Ralph breaks
the internet six years later we find
that Vanellope is feeling bored of Sugar
Rush and she ends up causing the game's
steering wheel to break when she Rebels
against the player's input what starts
out as a movie about Ralph helping
Penelope find a way to fix Sugar Rush
quickly becomes about him finding a
loophole that will let her move to a
completely different game instead the
more exciting and violent Slaughter race
even after sugar rush is fixed Penelope
decides to stay in slow to race instead
essentially rendering all the lessons
learned and rules established in the
first movie moot
all right
[Music]
in 1984 Daniel Larusso was fighting for
a lot of things in the first Karate Kid
movie confidence respect from his peers
praise from his Sensei but perhaps most
crucially he was seemingly fighting for
the right to date a girl named Ali Mills
like a true 1980s Underdog Daniel
eventually wins both the or Valley
karate tournament as well as a girl no a
woman shouldn't be a prize to be one but
again this was the 1980s come the Karate
Kid Part 2 and it turns out that Ali
wasn't his prize to keep anyway she's
nowhere to be seen in the 1986 sequel or
his 1989 follow-up with only brief
mention of her having left Dany on prom
night for a college football player
fortunately Ali's reputation would later
get some much needed Redemption when she
showed up in the Karate Kid sequel
series Cobra Kai to finally give her
side of the story about her breakup with
Daniel Ralph Macchio admitted in a 2022
interview with the guardian that he
regrets having not advocated for actor
Elizabeth Shu back in the 80s when
producers decided not to ask her back
after the first movie most of Rocky 2
feels like an undoing of everything that
made the original movie special in the
first film released in 1976 Rocky Balboa
winning was never the point it's not
considered a disappointing or downer
ending that he doesn't Triumph in the
big final bout because it's not supposed
to be about that he is his total
underdark not even a professional boxer
at this point holding his own for 15
full rounds against Apollo Creed Rocky
gives Apollo a good fight and that's all
that matters the two even reach mutually
respectful even friendly terms and agree
to never face off again
hang on being a rematch
the wrong one and then comes 1979's
Rocky 2 which immediately goes about
setting up the rematch that was never
supposed to happen also Rocky can
actually beat Apollo at the end of the
film this Arc isn't unlike what ended up
happening with Stallone's other big
franchises from that era as a very
grounded and human story of first blood
made way for the more cartoonish and
over-the-top Rambo sequels subsequent
Rocky movies get progressively further
away from what made the original and its
perfect ending the best in the series by
a long shot in one of the most perfectly
heartstring tugging movie endings of all
time 2010's Toy Story 3 raptor Pixar's
first Trilogy with Andy playing with his
beloved toys one last time before
passing them on to Bonnie it's a
Bittersweet moment for Andy and the
audience should be comforted to know
that the young girl will love them and
play with them for many years to come
Andy looking back at Woody one last time
as he drives away is the kind of moment
that requires a hard swallow whether
you're seeing it for the first time or
the 10th while the overall or consensus
is that 2019's Toy Story 4 ended up
somehow justifying its existence despite
how perfect of a conclusion Toy Story 3
was there's little to nine cops setting
the airs when the fourth installment
gets going you catch back up with Bonnie
only a short time later and she's
already over many of Andy's old toys we
were left to assume that the gang was
going to get the kind of attention they
hadn't gotten since Andy's childhood
only to discover that a number of the
toys had already been shoved into a
closet ask any longtime alien fan when
they think the franchise first started
to go downhill and they'll probably tell
you it began with alien 3. but what made
David Fincher's 1992's three calls so
unliked by audiences and critics it
probably had something to do with the
premature deaths of a few beloved
characters while James Cameron's aliens
adds even more xenomores to the mix it
also includes Alan Ripley to the Rough
and Tumble crew of the USS solaco among
them are Corporal Hicks and The
Scientist Android Bishop who helped
rescue Little Orphan nude from the alien
horde and managed to survive till the
end the film ends with a spark of hope
perhaps Our Heroes May be able to move
on and establish their own littlefound
family her weekend asleep all the way
home
Alien 3 doesn't hold on to that's hope
for long the opening of the film depicts
the group's Escape pod crashing into a
Maximum Security Prison killing Hicks
bishop and most tragically of all news
the majority of viewers came to hate the
opening to alien 3. and director David
Fincher ended up being one of them he
told the guardian they had to work on it
for two years got fired up it three
times and had to fight for every single
thing no one hated it more than me to
this day no one hates it more than me
foreign